so Frederick is from a life science
background he has done BSE in biomedical
science and MSA in biotechnology
so we have a lot of life science
students amongst us
and all of them are in a beginner level
except Frederick
so um do you have any particular
interest in such as oncology or
infectious diseases
what are your research interests I'm
curious to know about that too
some people are interested in space
omics some people are interested in
machine learning what are your research
interests
all right so we have a diverse range of
research interest amongst the
participants so abhimanyu says he is
interested in neurodegenerative diseases
and oncology and of course that says he
is interested in omic's data analyzing
in inflammation and inflammatory disease
varsha is interested in clinical
research and has also worked in medicine
research projects and is still exploring
research projects
that's a pretty cool diverse range of
Interest amongst the participants I'm
curious to know about rest of your
interest as well
all right so while we're waiting for the
participants to share their interest
I'll be starting with today's webinar so
hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is Krishna Kumar and
I would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on introduction to
bankmatics multi-ohmics this is an
online program and is designed for
everyone including students who don't
have a background in bioinformatics and
biologists to learn about next
Generation sequencing data analysis
including genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics as a result participants
will become proficient in the analysis
and interpretation of various types of
omics data using bioinformatics
including commonly used statistical and
machine learning techniques and in
today's webinar
we will first sign up on the omox logic
loan portal and learn how to navigate
the various courses that will be part of
your program followed by this we will go
through the details of the program such
as topics covered in each session
Associated coursework and example
projects finally we will cover the
details about the program registration
process and program cost
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omic Strategic
Training that has been completed by over
24
000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization track that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
students will also have access to the
omics logic resources but how does it
help Advance bioinformatics teaching
omic's logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics
it takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions mentors to give the student a
clear path of the Bloom's taxonomy
pyramid and no matter what the user's
initial experience with bioinformatics
is for mix logic is a useful tool for
gaining a baseline knowledge of the
theory behind bioinformatics analysis of
large data sets and introduction to
basic coding languages like R and python
or even beginning a data analysis
project
this also comes with an access to the
omaxology courses which includes courses
on bioinformatics Precision medicine
multiomics that includes genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using RN python as well
as cheminformatics and example projects
of different fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work users will be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections on
this multinomics platform
another important resource that you will
get access to as a part of the program
is access to the omics logic code
playground which will help you develop
coding skills while learning popular
packages in RN python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data
and with so much data available on any
biological topic and question completing
a program seems like a great opportunity
but it can be challenging that is why
you also have the opportunity to seek
mental guidance and learn alongside an
International Community of
bioinformatics and data science
enthusiasts
so now to view the various courses you
need to first sign up on the omics logic
loan portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features you need to update on
your account that is a completed profile
will have a profile image full name with
appropriate capitalization link to your
social media handles a brief bio about
yourself that will consist of your
educational background and research
interest the mentors can view your
progress under the activity Tab and the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses tab
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under these certificates app so with
that let us Begin by signing up on the
omic start learn portal
so I'm showing the link in the chat box
for the participants to sign up on the
portal
so here's a brief demonstration on how
to sign up on the portal so for those
participants who do not have an account
on the portal yet you can simply click
on the create an account option that you
see here
so once you click on this you can fill
out your name email ID and password or
you also have the option to sign up
using any of your social media accounts
such as Google Facebook Apple account
GitHub account or even Twitter and for
those participants who already have an
account on the portal you can simply
click on the login now option that you
see here and simply click on sign in and
with that I would like to pause for a
couple of seconds for the participants
to sign up on the portal
and if you already have have an account
on the portal please put a yes in the
chat box
and once you have signed up on the
portal please put it down in the chat
box and I'll proceed along how to show
the various courses and example projects
thanks everyone
visited the link and if you're having
any queries you can mention in the chat
box as well and I'll be happy to help
you
so we have one guest from abhimanyu I'm
expecting responses from the rest of as
well
because I'll be sharing links to the
coursework
and it'll be easy for you to open the
link and navigate through the various
lessons in the coursework for that you
need to have an account
so varsha says she's already registered
what about rest of the participants have
everyone signed up
so I'm going to sign into the portal but
along the way if you're having any
queries please do let me know
so once you sign in on the portal you'll
be able to see the various courses and
example projects so
in the search bar that says looking for
a specific course if you have a specific
research interest you can simply enter
that keyword for example let's say
you're interested in transcriptomics
so once you enter that keyword it will
show up various courses and example
projects that make use of that concept
and you can simply navigate through and
browse through and take a look at all of
the courses and example projects that
are there but for now coming to the part
where I was talking about updating your
account on the Bluetooth for that click
on the tab that says welcome back with
your email ID
so once you click here to update your
account you can simply click on the
button that says profile so once you
click on this you will be able to edit
all of your details that I explained in
my presentation
and this is the activity tab where the
community manager and the mentor for
your program will be tracking your
learning progress and the courses you
are currently completing will appear
under this course tab so once you
complete a project and upload it on the
portal that will be displayed under the
projects Tab and once you enroll for any
of the programs such as the introduction
to bioinformatics multiomics then that
will be appearing under the programs tab
so now let me show you through the
sessions of this program
so you can simply enter when you click
on the tab that says programs and enter
the
introduction to
mathematics it will show up the program
that you're interested
so if you navigate down below you'll be
able to see the various sessions that
will be there as per the program I'm
sharing the link in the chat box so that
the participants can have a look at it
so now going back to my presentation we
will take a look at each of what are
these sessions all about
so
we know that a digital Revolution is
happening in healthcare and humans are
being digitized through new devices apps
and monitoring Technologies which are
tracking analyzing and storing large
amounts of data and for many diseases
molecular data is increasingly important
and relies on complex bioinformatic
analysis and for many wet lab scientists
the analysis of large amount of data is
still a major bottleneck and against
this backdrop of this fast moving field
to address the challenges for
bioinformatic Education and Training we
have designed this program on
introduction to bioinformatics but that
romance so now let us go over the
sessions one by one and take a look at
the associated resources and the session
outcomes
so the very first session will be on
bioinformatics and Big Data here we will
introduce the participants to the
various fields of bioinformatics
important Concepts and its various
applications in biomedical research
and for this purpose we will be going
through a few introductory courses so
first of all you'll be asked to complete
for course one introduction to
bioinformatics where you will cover
topics on big data bioinformatics and
its uses in basic research Healthcare
and the biotechnology and pharmaceutical
Industries and at the end of the course
you will have a thorough understanding
of what is Big Data biology what are
various applications of bioinformatics
and Healthcare and what is translation
by informatics
and another interesting course that you
will be taking as part of the program is
course 2 bytes and molecules here you
will gain an understanding of how the
current revolution in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health and at the end of this course you
will be introduced to various omics
field including genomics metagenomics
and transcript comics but so far we have
been gaining an introductory level
knowledge of various omic spheres
so now we will go one step further and
explore each of these fields in detail
so now let's say a sick patient comes to
you with their blood or tissue sample
and you want to understand what genes
are affected what is contributing to his
or her disease for this we need to carry
out genomic data analysis so for this
purpose we have the second section that
will introduce the participants to
genomics that you will learn about DNA
various variants and mutations and other
topics covered during the session
include
germline and somatic mutations analysis
using mapping detecting variants and
interpretation of significant and
insignificant mutations
so now I'd like to
take you through the courses that will
be taught as a part of the session
this will be course 3 genomics and in
this lesson you you will be familiarized
with the biology of genetics and genetic
variation well-constring practical
applications
and at the end of the session you will
learn about waiting calling analysis to
process data and identify variants
between cancers and non-cancerous cell
genomes the full course also contains
other important Concepts such as
phylogenetic analysis mutability
analysis differential mutability
analysis and so on
so another important uh session will be
is on metagenomics so now I'd like to
ask you all a question so do microbial
communities have a role in contributing
to diseases
the answer is yes for instance a recent
study has found that the appearances of
Alzheimer's disease has been tightly
associated with changes in the skin
microbiota
and with the pace at which metagenomics
data is generated recently is
astonishing so that is why we have
designed this session for metagenomics
and there will be two sessions for this
first is designed to introduce the
participants to the various fields of
metagenomics and the second session is
for introducing the participants to
metagenomic sequencing and its various
applications
and as a part of the session you will be
directed to course 4 metagenomics
wherein you will learn to analyze
microbiome composition and species
diversity using metagenomics data
and at the end of the session you will
gain a basic understanding of data 2 or
kind 2 analysis of amplicon sequencing
you will also learn to interpret the
outputs including Alpha diversity beta
diversity and even taxonomic abundance
plots to understand the evolutionary
Trend through phylogenic analysis
so now another interesting question is
is it possible to find patterns in the
gene expression between a healthy and a
sick patient
and if so how can we do that for this
purpose we will be making use of
transcriptomics data for example the
image displayed in front of you is part
of a study wherein the researchers try
to compare gene expression changes
in the immune responses before and
during malaria infection in the patients
but how do we analyze it
so for this purpose we have designed two
more sessions on transcriptomic data
analysis in the first session we will
learn about gene expression data
analysis followed by this in the next
session you will learn about
differential gene expression analysis
and as a part of this section you will
be directed to course 5 transcriptomics
wherein you will learn how the same
genome can give rise to different cell
types and how gene expression is
regulated
and at the end of the session you will
have a thorough understanding about
transcriptomics data analysis Downstream
analysis of transcriptomics data from
basic visualization to statistical
analysis of differentially expressed
genes all done by using the popular dc2
package and you will also learn about
biological interpretation and annotation
of Gene sex
so the about two sessions were solely
focused on bulk RNA sequencing wherein
you will be looking at the gene
expression at a large scale but is it
possible to identify gene expression
pattern of individual cell let's say in
a tumor ecosystem
the answer is yes
unlike the conventional bulkarni
sequencing methods the Single Cell RNA
sequencing provides an unbiased insight
into the gene expression pattern of each
individual cell thereby providing a
comprehensive look into the mechanisms
of cell to cell infections and to help
you gain these skills we have designed
the introduction to single cell transfer
conversation and as a part of this
session you will be directed to course 6
single cell RNA transcriptomics wherein
you will learn about single cell RNA
sequencing how it is generated how to
analyze it and what specific challenges
need to be considered
and at the end of the session you will
have a thorough understanding of marker
genes umap and tsne plots feature plots
violin plots Rich plots and even
assigned clusters to cells based on
observed differentially expressed genes
and these plots are not just useful to
understand what the Single Cell
expression is but they will also add
weightage to researchers findings and
publications
finally we also have another interesting
topic so let's say we have collected the
data on eye color gender age height and
weight of people we hypothesize that
some variables here are related and some
are not and we also think there are
exceptions to the rule the age and
height or weight are related but not
always
relationships observed in data can show
which variables are related unrelated
and if related then by how much
for example the weight and height seems
to be logically related are they in this
data
sorry okay if you plot a trend line you
will find that the trend line goes up
and the higher the height weight also
increases but the dots are not too close
to the line some dots seem to be far
away from it and is there a way to find
to quantify this relationship we found
so to help you solve important questions
and biology such as these you will be
introduced to two more sessions on
introduction to buy ml using statistical
analysis
as well as bioinformatics NGS machine
learning projects and as a part of the
session you will be directed to course 7
bio ml machine learning for biomedical
data where you will learn about various
statistical methods of data analysis
including unsupervised unsupervised
machine learning that can be applied to
biomedical data and using various
examples of omix data we will see how
such analysis can yield significant
results for various biomedical
applications
and at the end of the session you will
have a thorough understanding of data
mining and machine learning
wherein you can perform supervised and
unsupervised analysis to analyze
Patterns group data objects by feature
similarity and trained machine learning
models for predicted analysis
so now that we have completed with the
coursework what comes next in the final
session you will learn how to apply the
knowledge gained so far from the
coursework to example projects wherein
you will learn about how to download
data sets from publicly available
domains such as ncbi Geo Etc and now for
all of that and more I'd like to pass on
the stage to Dr raghavendan Lakshmi
Narayan who will also be the program
Mentor for this introduction to
bioinformatics so over to you sir
thank you very much recovery let me set
up let me set up my screen share
and I I think we have a question from uh
from a participant can you please
yeah unmute yourself and ask your
question we will
or you can type it in the chat box if
you want
so please let me know if you have raised
your hand by mistake
the human
what is your question
let us know
okay there is another question yes parul
please
I think
so let's
if you have question please type it in
the chat box uh we cannot wait longer
for uh people to get your questions done
so um we will turn to your questions
once you type it in the chat box or if
you I'm giving you a couple of minutes
chance now yeah great
okay you have a question that all the
chat details are only about medical or
drug designs
Assad I mean from my own experience the
issue with plant Sciences right we
cannot
I mean first we cannot uh Corner
everything like only for about medical
or drug designs the uh the development
in the omics data analysis in the
translational field and medical
applications is because we have very
well defined uh analysis setups and
pipelines and sequences for completing
those analysis
a with respect to and also very well
defined reference sequences for for
several of the organisms that we are
trying to study including humans and
other bacteria Etc but I have also
worked with lot of plants
genomic sequences the issue there is
first we do not have a complete
reference genome for many of the plant
sequences and even if you could find one
then the problem the complexity of the
plant genome sequence is actually
requires a different setup and a
different collection of algorithms and
different set different parameters to be
used in a trial and error basis to
extract maximum output and maximum
interpretation from a from a plant
genomics data right so such a
method and such uh such a vast human
intervention based uh technique is not
viable for our analysis and not variable
for many of the resources we have data
regarding our data pertaining to plant
Sciences where
we have uh for example transcriptomics
data analysis for plant sequence or
plant mRNA sequences and input to
understand drought resistance in potato
and we also have identification of
contamination in
um
uh in in for example uh uh
um yeah in in related to uh mod
sequences and uh uh yeah and uh and
other plant sequences right and we also
have uh metagenomics data analysis of uh
soil I think soil or isobium I forgot so
those are the data analysis where we
have very well defined steps in order to
maximize the interpretation and also
give you value if you want to perform
other analysis like uh genomics sequence
analysis and this
Assad you tell me where are the data
where are the reference sequences for
the serial crop
right therein lies the complexity
that is why uh the availability of
publicly available resources right that
is why we we even if we want to perform
that all of these analysis will need a
specific
curated analysis sequences pipelines
need to be set up for several of that
and even if we could present you
a whole genomics data analysis for one
specific plant genome that might not be
the same steps are same the setups and
parameters that you are going to apply
for another plan job then we cannot
generalize if we cannot generalize then
we cannot prepare generalized material
that is why we have limited resources on
plant cells not only us you take any uh
available uh Publications right they
have different methods pertaining to
plan genome sequences that's why but
wherever it is available we are trying
to expand our resources to include plant
data also okay
um
yeah so
okay coming back to your questions right
uh Assad wants to do uh
understand about single cell
transcriptomics of Serial crops right so
we can break this down further right if
your focus is on understanding the
analysis of single cell transcriptomics
data we have plenty of resources on that
right you can set aside the system and
understand the process
and maybe by that way you can adapt this
process to suit your system
that is that is how you can proceed uh
if I if you want my uh interpretation
about how can I proceed with given given
this condition and uh Dr Rita wants to
do analysis of maize against fungal
diseases
it is actually possible to do if you
have reference sequence for your maze
species
please mute yourself
and we have a very closely related uh
project Exemplar project which I might
not be focusing on discussing today but
we have it in the uh we have it in the
learn portal about how to map the
sequences to a known reference sequence
and then take the unmapped reads and
then try to identify from which fungal
or viral source that these unmapped
reads are going to come from so your
question Dr Rita is very similar to this
this method will work only if you have
a good reference sequence genome
sequence for your maze specialist so
that is a must if you do not have then
it's going to be very difficult to
participate in this analysis because
work is work with this analysis because
you have to do denovo genomics data
analysis where the de novo analysis
platform uh or algorithm will will also
take your fungal sequences and start
building up contigues and
contents for that okay and assemblies
for that so that is why
yes we are going to talk about that in
in in my session so parul please wait
for that so let's go over
yeah let's go over what what we have in
store for uh trying to apply what you
would have learned so far when going
through this program right the program
is going to teach you our program is
going to give you a general overview a
great overview of what are the different
analysis options you have and what are
the different uh setup options for for
um for those analysis algorithms and
when you should use what algorithms and
in what combination you will use this
algorithm to study what right to give
you a more practical approach of all of
these or several of these analysis
options we have prepared several of
these Exemplar projects in the learn
product so what are these Exemplar
projects these exemplary projects will
take data from publicly available
resources from a publication or from
from public repositories and then
start asking relevant biological
questions to these data right if it is
from publication we are going to ask a
slightly different question than what
has been addressed in that publication
and then just like how to approach a
research project we will approach that
question by setting up methods and then
we will perform those analysis with the
resources that we have and then we will
interpret the results and then we will
implicate them biologically at the end
and compare it with their original
publication or compare it with the
publication that refers to these data
generally this is the structure of
several of the example projects that we
have and for some of them we are going
to or I am going to give you an
introduction how what you will be
learning throughout the course of this
program right so if
I hope my uh um screenshot is working so
the applications of bioinformatics is is
um is very well explained by SRI gauri
so if you are an absolute beginner so
and SRI Gary also mentioned this I would
want you to start with these getting
started courses like you can start with
introduction to bioinformatics you can
start with bytes and molecules if you
want to expand your horizons or expand
your knowledge into scripting world you
can start with bioinformatics in R and
bioinformatics in Python although it is
not absolutely necessary to learn
scripting to perform bioinformatics as
we are going to present it to you you
can use the resources as we will
demonstrate you how to use the big data
bioinformatic resource of how about
bioinfo platform to perform all the
necessary analysis and understand the
biology behind this data analysis Big
Data biophistics right
and after this you will be able to see
or after this program or throughout the
course of this program you will be able
to see how NGS data and bioinformatics
are used in various research areas that
includes Neuroscience agriculture
infectious diseases oncology and Etc so
as um as discussed earlier also we have
several examples on some of these topics
and few examples on the other topics so
if you want to get creative on applying
one method to another system so you are
very welcome to do that and that is how
active research has been carried out as
well
so let's start this with trying to
understand how the course genomics or
the coursework or the resources that we
find in genomics can be applied to a
practical example right this course is
going to give you a complete overview of
what are the different analysis that you
can set up for genomics data analysis
right as mentioned right and and how to
choose specific analysis type for
specific question is what is answered in
several of the example projects some of
the projects that are associated with
genomic set analysis is to understand
the SARS scope to variants from
Wastewater subtitles that's an excellent
project and to for example to do a
comparative analysis of phylogenetic
tree analysis and evolutionary
reconstruction of zoonotic trans
transmission of sarscope to variance or
source group to virus from species to
species in a comparative whole genome
sequence analysis that's also that but
what we are going to focus here is to
understand for example by the use of
mutational analysis how drug resistance
in pathogens are going to be developed
so we know that we know about
mycobacterium tuberculosis and we know
the background of tuberculosis and how
mycobacterium tuberculosis is very very
important to study being that is the
leading cause of death in in several of
these countries apart from cancer right
and one of the main problems with
dealing with mycobacterium tuberculosis
pathogen is it can for example develop
resistance to most of the antibiotic
that it gets or that it is that the
patients are treated with so this also
gives us a for example a general
complication in not only in tuberculosis
also in in other pathogens on how these
pathogens develop these drug resistance
and can we eat
excuse me from genomics data and
Analysis can we pinpoint the driver
genes or driver mutations that are
responsible for the drug resistance of
these pathogens
right yeah
and
the increasing prevalence of this drug
resistance forms of TB infections for
example obviously requires more
effective and more personalized
treatment strategies right but the
problem is the current standard regimen
actually includes combinations of
different antibiotics or combination of
different types of antibiotics for a
longer period of time and all of these
current regimen treatment regimen are
prone to develop drug resistance in the
pathogen right the ideal scenario for
the pathogens to develop drug resistance
is prolonged exposure to the antibiotic
so that is definitely in this regimen
and prolonged exposure to multiple types
of antibiotics that is also in this
structure so
we have to strike a balance between
treating the pathogen and also not
letting the pathogen develop resistance
to these drugs
to this track but in in between these
analysis if we can understand how this
drug resistance is actually been
developed we can Target specifically to
those pathogens and then try to
eliminate those pathogens from the uh um
from the Infectious person right
so
this is to show that how complicated uh
this drug resistance can get for example
over the course of this drug resistance
development of drug resistance in the
pathogens the pathogens can actually
develop resistance to multiple drugs
which is called multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis or extensively
xdr extensive drug resistance it is been
clocked or it's been counted that
multiple drug resistant tuberculosis can
be resistant to almost 38 or 39
different drugs right and extensive drug
resistant tuberculosis can be this is
resistant to up to 71 different drugs so
both of these are extremely dangerous
and and we do not have effective plants
to treat these drug resistant
microbacterium tuberculosis so
so how are these actually generated or
how are these drug resistant actually is
developed so there are generally four
groups of uh anti-tuberculosis drugs and
the classification is actually based on
the mechanism of action of these drugs
right and whenever there is a drug
mechanism involved and whenever there is
a gene that is involved in this drug
mechanism then the genes um
that are targeted in the pathogenic
system also has a susceptibility to
develop mutations that are that can
resist this targeting mechanisms so that
is why stochastic mutations
targeting these Associated genes can
lead to resistance of resistant to those
specific drugs that are targeting that
are targeting these particular genes so
this information also gives us a window
to probe these genes for known
characterized and also unknown and
uncharacterized variants and mutations
that you can identify from performing uh
a straightforward genomic data analysis
or variant calling pipeline analysis
that is what we are going to do in this
specific project so this specific
project deals with this publication
where this is a wonderful publication
where it uh
it attracts the drug resistant
development of one pathogen in a single
patient for 21 years so over the course
of this 21 years the patient was given
different treatment regimes and then
um the development of the drug resistant
to different of different drugs and
different antibiotics is what is
recorded and then we have a window or we
have a unique opportunity to take the
isolates at different time points of
this one specific MDR variant and to
understand how different mutations and
how different genomic variants can lead
to development of resistant to several
of these listed antibiotics that this
pathogen came into a contention right so
to perform this analysis we use a
straightforward variant calling analysis
right we map the sequences or we map the
isolates reads onto the reference in
sequence of mycobacterium tuberculosis
and then we visualize for visual
confirmation and then we perform a
variant calling pipeline there are
different of these variant calling
pipelines some of them will work better
than the other so it's always very
helpful to try
more than one so it is often done uh
more than one type of variant calling
algorithm is actually used and then
sometimes the consensus is actually used
to uh used for Downstream analysis or
the sorry the union of these variant
identified are actually used for
downshift analysis that's what we will
actually do and what you will actually
gain is to understand and identify what
is the variant that is statistically
relevant right from visualizing these
variants from bam file and VCF file and
to for example identify those relevant
or key variant that we want to focus on
that could be responsible for the
development of these resistant drug
resistance in this microbacterium
tuberculosis right
and that is what we are going to do in
this specific project so if you are
interested in trying out this project
before uh proceeding so you are
extremely free to check this out right
okay
so what do we have here okay this is uh
yeah this we don't want to focus now
okay so um the all the information and
all the analysis uh steps to perform
this analysis and the interpretation to
how to interpret the outputs and how to
compare it with what was actually
published is actually given in this
project thanks recovery for uh for
pasting the project link so that is how
you understand how to set up for example
how to use a variant calling pipeline
analysis of genomics data to understand
and multiple drug resistant in
microbacterium tuberculosis so this
gives you an opportunity to take this
analysis and modify it for your needs
right the data does not have to come
from this one particular resource you
can find completely freely available
multiple drug resistant
publicly available data from ncbi or
from other publication and then try to
repeat this analysis and find find the
difference between the variants that you
identify for your data and what we have
identified as per described in this
specific publication that's why you
start learning how to apply these
analysis methods to a variety of
different data so let's move ahead
and
discuss about what can we learn from
metagenomics data analysis and how
how for example applying metagenomics
data analysis to one specific project
will help us gain a deeper understanding
of the general overview of metagenamics
data analysis so again what the course
contains uh what are the contents of the
course and what are the contents of the
projects and how they differ is already
been discussed in the previous set so
this also follows the same the course is
going to give you a complete overview of
all different possible analysis options
that you can perform for different data
generated from different systems the
data can come from Human control human
samples right like human American gut
microbiome project or data can come from
a model system which we are going to
discuss today right
and that is also possible right and what
are the uh for example patterns in the
data when you are considering data from
a model system or when you are
considering data from Human Resources is
what will be
um is what that determines the um
interpretability of your risks so
generally for any system the control
that the model system gives you also uh
helps you to increase the signal to
noise ratio and the lack of control that
one one has to encounter with the human
data is actually associated with more
noise that we want to eliminate or that
we want to suppress during the course of
our data analysis so the methods to do
that and where to focus on which part of
analysis to focus for what model system
is will be the focus will be the uh
a main takeaway from this specific
course right so let's focus on one
particular aspect right so
this has already been discussed and we
already know right in healthy adults gut
microbiome the microbiome that is
existing inside our human gut that it
actually exists in a state of mutual
symbiosis with us like the host right
the environment of this symbiosis or
this gut actually dictates both the
composition of these microbes and the
functional productivity of this
microbiota right
and this microbiota has been known to
interact with the host through various
ligands and various molecules that that
also forms many key important metabolite
that we have to rely on to process the
day process the food or to generate
energy or for immune response and and
they are implicated in several of
different biological processes from our
body itself right so
due to this interaction we now have an
understanding that gut microbiome has an
enormous impact on the life of a post
and what impacts or what has more impact
on this cut microbiome itself is the
diet that we take right the diet that we
take place a fundamental role in shaping
the composition of this microbiome and
and this function and hence this also
leads to for example this also leads so
how the food is actually processed and
how much energy that we are actually
extracting and how it generally affects
um
our other bodily functions due to the
balance or imbalance in the gut
microbiome that is present in our body
right with that background let's move on
to this specific project so this
specific project is uh it deals with the
role of high fat diet right to
understand how high fat diet is going to
shape the gut microbiota the system that
we are going to deal here is the mouse
model system right a model system gives
you more flexibility of completely
eradicating all the microbiota that is
present in the gut of this mouse or
these mice and then start rebuilding
those microbiota based on the diet that
we are giving these mice
um
yeah based on the
diet regimes that we are giving these
are providing these mice right so there
are two types of mice that we are going
to deal with one is given a normal diet
which is um
ciao diet and the other mice is given
high fat diet so we are going to find
out the imbalance or symbiosis or
dysbiosis relationship between the
microbiota and their dietary components
right this publication is wonderful uh
in in essence because it has lot of
layers it not only studies the imbalance
that is generated by the diet right it
also studies the behavioral effect of
these microbiota symbiosis that is
generated due to the dietary
supplements right so for this project we
will show you how to set up amplicon
sequencing analysis of amplicon
sequencing data using data to Pipeline
and then
yeah and then we will show you
how to interpret the results from let's
say a proportional abundance plot or
abundance plot of um
of different regulatory diets so in this
for example
um data if you check
um
yeah virus
yes for example in this data you can
check that there are several of the
bacteria that are abundant in in high
fat today compared to the regular diet
for example the phylum sakurobacteria
and phylum for example
um
actino bacteria are abundant in Haifa
diet but they are completely missing in
uh in these ones so that is what we will
learn and also we will learn to identify
those specific bacterial phyla or genus
or species that are that one can
identify being
um
particularly or specifically abundant in
one type of phenotypical conditions are
sample conditions which here is a high
fat diet or child iron so we see that
the composition of for example
bacterialities versus spermicutes
changes depending upon how many um
samples that we are depending upon what
these samples are actually where the
samples are actually collected from
right
and furthermore
this project will also show you how to
perform a grouped
abundance analysis like Alpha diversity
and beta diversity which can help you
summarize the diversity of population
and in each of these phyla or members
that belongs to uh
these different dietary samples are
samples from different dietary regimes
right
um
we can learn what the alpha diversity
shows us right how we can estimate the
number of species or how even the
species spread is between the samples
right that's what we can learn from the
alpha diversity and we can see what uh
what differentiates right how the
samples are differentiated based on the
amount of diversity present
within them and between them by
analyzing the beta diversity so this is
what we will
get to learn in this project so what do
we understand by trying to learn or
going through the process of Performing
this analysis and trying to relate to
these difference in diversity and
difference in abundance to different
populations or two different uh sample
conditions or different dietary samples
with different dietary regimes is we can
for example
take uh or we can measure the level of
symbiosis or dysbiosis within the system
[Music]
as a function of these abundance of
different microbial populations at the
rank that you choose to if you want to
understand the population based on file
based on the phyla level we can do that
and implicate that to different disease
cases right and uh we if you want to
understand
uh the population with a bit more
resolution we can go up to genus level
and understand their uh composition also
so there are certain limitations in
going beyond the genus level as you will
learn throughout the course of this uh
project uh that um where these level
ends and what to do if you encounter lot
of uncharacterized uh microbial
population right so
in the end the aim is to relate the
abundance of these microbiota to for
example uh to understand the change in
their balance from symbiosis uh
condition to the this biotic condition
and com and relate that to
implicate that to different dietary
conditions or different phenotypical
conditions of the data or different
disease state if we are going to
um
focus on that so this project focuses on
understanding that this biotic
development of microbial population due
to the role of high fat diet in in the
samples so that is where we are going to
focus this so I want to stop at this
point and ask if you have any questions
so
um security if you can paste the link
for this particular project that will be
great and if you have yeah thank you
very much if you have uh any questions
please put that up in the chat and then
we will quickly go through what we will
learn through learn in the next few
project examples right I want to rush
this a little bit because we are short
of time so the next section or sessions
that you are going to encounter is
transcriptomic State analysis and
transcriptomics course itself is a huge
course and it has lots and lots of
options to perform how these
transcriptomics data analysis can be
performed through different combinations
of analysis methods right I don't want
to go over everything because we have
project example that that addresses each
and every one of these combination if
you want to for example map this onto uh
the genome we have a project example for
that if you want to map the reads onto
the for example isoforms to get isoform
expression level we have a project
number if you want to build your own
transcripts we have a project on that
so please go and explore different
project examples for transcriptomics
data analysis so that is going to uh be
very helpful because transcriptomics
data is the most used data in the in the
spectrum of atomic status for
implicating in several of diseases or
biological conditions or phenotypical
conditions and to understand generally
disease progression development of
mutation the development of
cancer and lot of other applications
implications also right so what are we
going to
thank you
focus on today so today the focus is on
understanding the transcriptomics
landscape of Alzheimer's disease and try
to find some relevant Pathways that are
that can be implicated in the disease uh
um
biology or disease progression of
Alzheimer's disease right I don't want
to go over the background of Alzheimer's
disease we everybody knows that how um
how progressively neurodegenerative this
disease disorder or disease can be and
people actually usually start from
suffering from loss of memory and
cognitive functions and also uh
eventually leading to the loss of
ability to respond to devil environment
and and even to perform daily tasks
right so let's uh
go over we will deal with how to prepare
data for for example to understand uh
different ways of data pre-processing
for exploratory data analysis like PCA
or performing
um
quantile normalization or histogram
analysis and what these analysis are
going to show us or tell us right we are
looking for for example here we are
looking for good separation between
samples from Alzheimer's disease and
sample from controllers so what can what
you can learn from this PCA or
explorative data analysis I can learn
that that is in addition to these
samples being separated based on the
disease state or control there is also a
decent level of separation between some
of the samples Within These disease
levels right they might affect my data
analysis or they might not so it depends
upon I can check the phenotypical
characteristics of the data and
understand their separation or I can
just proceed forward right it is safe to
proceed in this case why because of the
tidbits that we will discuss in this
session like the scale of the principal
component axis here and here does not
warrant a special investigation of why
these samples are far apart right the
scale is extremely minimal and it is
okay if they are little bit far apart so
that is not going to affect our data
analysis so we proceed with performing
differential gene expression analysis to
understand genes that are differentially
expressed or that are upregulated or
down regulated and we can perform some
very well known analysis like volcano
plots and LFC plot ma plot and Etc
and and identify Pathways that are
associated with these differential
Express genes and pathway Association
analysis right by performing these
pathway analysis and identifying
Pathways associated in the gene ontology
terms or in the cake pathway
repositories we can for example
understand what are the different uh uh
different
[Music]
um
enriched Pathways or suppressed Pathways
that can be implicated in the disease
progression of this Alzheimer's disease
case right that is what our ultimate aim
to right when you perform this analysis
uh as described in this project
eventually you will try to or you will
come uh to a uh understanding that
several of the synaptic pathways are
impaired in the Alzheimer's disease
patients and and several of the other
pathways are actually suppressed or
activated like immune response and other
pathways are activated in the
Alzheimer's disease patients and we can
find biological reasoning or
implications for these Pathways based on
that this is
this excuse me this and several other
examples of what to learn from
performing a simple straightforward
transcriptomics landscape analysis based
on differential gene expression analysis
for Alzheimer's disease uh pathology is
given in this project so please go
through if you are interested in this
this is just one example project that is
based on transcriptomic state analysis
we have several projects that focuses on
a different sections or different
applications of transcriptomic State
analysis like in understanding that
drought resistance to understanding the
cancer biology right and understanding
the host response to SARS right
understanding the effectiveness of drug
response in cancer right cancer cell
lines so there are several of these
applications and we we want to showcase
and finally right this this is an
interesting project and excellent
project if you want to learn about how a
sample data can be uh or how for example
cell lines data that is recorded for
multiple omics characteristics station
and and their drug response to several
different uh therapeutic options for
breast cancer been studied and we can
perform in this project we show you how
to use turbo bioinfo platform to perform
unsupervised data analysis unsupervised
machine learning analysis and supervised
machine learning analysis on this data
to understand for example
compressed cancer subtypes and to use
multi-omics integration to understand
drug response to 70 different drugs that
is tried on these submites right that is
what this particular project deals with
and all of this you can do without
coding right the aim is to make you
understand the logic behind these
analysis and
if you are interested in expanding uh
expanding your knowledge to include
coding we have same analysis or same
projects done on our or Python's
platform also so
with that I will conclude my session and
pass this past the stage on to sonalika
and I am free to take some questions if
you have any and and I look forward to
meet all of you over the course of this
program over to you sonalika and thanks
thank you srigori for pasting all of the
links for the projects and they are very
useful thank you
thank you so much Dr raka
okay
is my screen visible
yes
thank you so I would like to now take
you all through the program page of the
program introduction to bioinformatics
and on this program page you will find
the schedule of the program on which all
dates we have different sessions
scheduled and what all topics are we
going to cover for each and every
session and along with the session
topics you also have some Associated
online resources which are the lessons
from different courseworks on the omics
logic learn portal these resources are
hyperlinked so if you just click on the
specific resource you'll be redirected
to the specific lesson of the course
that you have to take up as a part of
this session
now this is the schedule that you can go
through one more thing on the program
page itself you will find the zoom link
when you have to connect for the
specific session on the program page
itself we will also email you the zoom
link that you have to join for each one
of these sessions and once the session
is over and the recording is processed
we'll upload the recording of the
session on the program page itself so
let's say you are not able to join the
live session because of uh some
priorities then you can watch the
recording of the session and come back
to us later with any questions that you
might have
now I like to open up another program
pages to give you an example how the
recordings are put up on the program
page that the uh participants can access
after the program also you can reposit
the uh topics that were covered during
the session
once the session is complete once you
have watched the recording and once you
have completed the resources you need to
click on the complete session button
like this I'm taking an example of
another program right now because
multi-oh makes introduction to
bioinformatics is yet to begin so the
program page is not yet active
and once you click on the complete
session like this for all of these
sessions once you have completed this
for all the sessions you will be able to
get your certificate uh in the profile
tab itself
so that was about the schedule where you
can find it where the resources are
listed what topics will we cover and
also how you can find the recording of
the session on the program page itself
now the next thing is for those
participants who are yet to enroll
themselves for the program if you scroll
down on the program page itself I'll
just put the link all right thank you so
much SRI body for putting the link of
the program page in the chat so the link
is in in the chat now once you scroll
down you can find three different levels
of subscriptions that you can pick to
enroll yourself for the program the
first one is the 45 days and then you
have 16 and 90 days now the duration of
the training program remains 45 days
that is all the sessions all the
training material would be covered in
the 45 days itself what additional do
you get if you enroll for 60 or 90 days
is the chance to work on a research
project and get it published so that is
the difference and that is the
additional thing that comes apart from
the training so once your training is
complete you are supposed to submit a
research proposal to us after the
training and then we start working on
your research project everything would
be under Mentor guidance and then you
complete your project then submit it
so these are the different pricing that
is mentioned for all these different
subscription levels now uh we are
offering partial scholarship that is 50
off on all of these different
subscription levels uh shubham will just
be sharing the link uh or the coupon
code the coupon code is there in the
chat box it's multi 50. you need to
click on the buy now button if you want
to enroll for the program and put the
coupon code here once you put the coupon
code uh you will get a partial
scholarship for the program and then you
can proceed via stripe or PayPal if
you're not able to proceed with uh these
payment options then you can reach out
to our team on marketing at the rate
omixlogic.com they'll be able to share
with you in a payment link or the other
options as well that you can choose from
to end yourself for the program so that
is how you check out for the
subscription level that you want to pick
and enroll for the program and if you
face any issues feel free to reach out
to us SRI gauri has shared the details
in the chat box already our team will be
there to help you enroll yourself and
get started
so now here you can see that the pricing
is mentioned in dollars now let's say if
you are from a different country and
have a different currency you can go on
top and click on the specific currency
um that belongs to you now I'm in India
for me it's INR so I'll just select INR
and then the pricing would be changed to
INR and the same process you apply the
coupon code and then you can see the
partial amount through which you have to
proceed further
so that was about the three different
subscription levels and what additional
do you get so in the 60 days you will be
able to work on a research proposal and
the outcome could be a poster
presentation and then in the 90 days you
could work on a research project itself
again with one-on-one Mentor sessions
and you will get a research license on
the T bioinfo server where users can
upload their data and then run on the
Pipelines so that is the difference in
three subscription levels now if there
are any questions you can please put in
the chat box so that we can answer
regarding subscriptions or
uh scholarships
yes definitely
uh so as I mentioned
that once you complete the training
program then you can work on a research
project and it's not that uh you have to
work on a research project that we offer
you like a topic that we offer you if
you have a research proposal and if you
want to work on your research question
you can definitely propose it to the
mentor and then start working on it
Azad this was for you
yes
any other questions
so if you are focusing on swargum we uh
want to know what type of research
question you want to answer related to
the specific
um us plant and then if you have a
shortlisted data set for yourself
perfect if not then throughout the
training you'll be also taught how to
extract data set so you can then select
a specific data set and you have to
provide a background of your research
question so we have a research proposal
form that we generally give to our
participants so we'll give you a
research proposal form where you have to
mention your research question the
background of your research whatever
literature review you have conducted and
what exactly you want to answer the link
to your data set and some of the
references that you went through and
referring which you want to to work on
the question that's it you need to
prepare a few presentations once you
complete your training program we will
have an orientation session with you
where we will explain everything how you
have to start with your research
question so there we generally tell that
how you have to prepare your
presentation of the research proposal
and present it to your Mentor the mentor
will then let you know if any
modifications are required if there are
then you can meet them and get started
with your project
proposal form as well please fill in the
details so that we can discuss on your
topic and Azad please put your email
address in the chat so that we can have
a one-on-one call with you to discuss
the specific research topic that you
want to work on and then we can get
started
thank you Azad
uh we have a question by nashmia what is
the course study the course commences on
23rd January
uh price in Euros yes I can if you go on
top
and scroll here and you select the euro
currency then you can find the pricing
here 149 Euros or 45 days 299 for 60
days and 499 for 90 days but again there
is a partial scholarship that we are
offering so if you put the code it would
be half of the amounts that are
mentioned here for each one of these
subscription levels
um Nashville this was sorry this was for
Estella
thank you so much for sharing its multi
50 and also we will be sending out an
email uh with the coupon code that you
can uh use if you copy the coupon code
right now perfect otherwise you'll also
get via email and those who are
entrusted to uh enroll themselves with
the partial scholarship they can put
their email address in the chat box so
that uh
um the representatives can help you get
started with your journey
you can shift from 45 days to 90 days
after completing the 45 days of the
training time period
all right are there any more questions
you can still ask our team is here we
can assist you
all right so
uh instead of the code is for everyone
for any participant who wants to enroll
for the program they can use the code
they can be undergraduate students
postgraduate students PhD Scholars
researchers anyone from non-bio and
fulfilled from buyer and for anyone who
wants to enroll
estina please share your email address
so that the team can reach out to you
with the details
thank you
all right so if you have no more
questions I think we are going to end
today's session and again if you have
any further questions that you want to
ask me later or by an email please feel
free to mail us at marketing
omicslogic.com and we'll be glad to
assist you
thank you everyone for joining today's
session it was nice interacting with you
all we'll meet you in the program thank
you bye
thank you everyone